if you live for the weekends your [__]
is broken right and I know this because
school was a disaster for me and when I
tell you that when there was a potential
snow day I turned into literally a
scientist I knew everything I mean I
probably had a poster of the Doppler
radar in my high school attention is the
number one
asset I have a special place in my heart
for you and not because of your uh
entrepreneurial expertise and not
because of your ESS what about my looks
not because of that not because of that
no that's where I kind of you're
gorgeous people don't know this but and
you probably watch him online and things
like that but he's even more stunning in
person Sparkle thank you you're very
sweet she is that's my kid okay um but I
I think that you are this generation's
philosopher you're very nice no but and
and I think that people uh grasp on to
you and your philosophies and you know
in thousands of years ago when we
listened to philosophers you know it was
uh to get maybe peace of mind I think
that the measure of your philosophy is
your success you know and and people
maybe listen to you more because they
can look at how many dollars or that you
can make or how many followers you can
get by following your philosophy but I
think that your philosophy is so much
deeper than views and likes and bucks
and and whatever and that is
and I'll let you speak to it in a minute
but this is what I've attached myself to
uh people ask me what what word of
advice would you give and I always said
before I I knew you it was Nike and
that's just do it you know and and I
believe that as human beings we have
this superpower called Instinct yes and
I think we all don't follow Instinct I
agree because we think and thinking and
fear that's what thinking yeah 100% go
ahead no no no please cuz you're on a
roll I was I was just trying to jam you
know like the band these are all your
you know what's funny and you know this
I'm I hope you can see them I get the
goose I always like when I always enjoy
when I think someone sees it the
greatest joys in my life even as a child
getting DFS was big shout out Mrs
Kennedy Spanish teacher she got it she
was one of the only ones that in those
12 years of my life that got it which
was I was above this 1980s School
structure not because I was cool or I
knew how to made money I just knew and
like when I hear you start this show
it's uncomfortably humbling because I
appreciate it because it's funny when
you were talking I'm like yeah the
businessman me and the social media I'm
just kind of almost using that to trick
them to listen well you're not tricking
it I I I I use I use trick as a slang
term thank you for jumping in what I say
by that is I'm
pumped that the certain parts of my life
whe whether it's the entrepreneurship
part whether it's the Jersey part part
whether it's the competitive part
whether it's the Jets fan whatever it is
I'm thrilled that I got Fortune enough
with in the DNA circumstance parenting
game that gave me something that will
allow people to take a look and then I
can start my thing to your point like
I've I'm incredibly motivated by this
weird mix of guilt and gratitude like I
don't even you know you and I listen
back to you being a fan like I'm I was
born in I'm 48 years old I know a lot
about you long before you didn't have
hair I like I do you know how much
admiration I have for your generation
comic do you know how much work that was
you know how lucky these kids are if
they had the same Talent you had and you
have they're three Tik Tok videos away
from starting the level of [__] that you
and your contemporaries AKA work effort
all those shows all that work all those
auditions all that work it's instant
aneous now in today's world if you have
the talent and so you know I appreciate
you seeing what you've seen in me from
afar and I'm pumped to be here and I'm
thrilled to be on the show and I'm
pumped but the the the where I will
argue with is that I I think just by
being human yes you have a talent I
agree and I think the difference between
when people look at entrepreneurship
when they look at people like Steve Jobs
or they look at people like Bezos or
they look at people like you the
difference between that person listening
and watching you and them is they're
just not doing it well a couple things
oh please you you had mentioned
previously about your Spanish teacher
and the 1980s way of like doing stuff in
school do you think that maybe part of
the problem is I'm a teacher and I love
education but school system and putting
people in this box and in this bubble
and there's one right way to do it and
it kind of stifles the creativity or
makes you more fearful to go out and do
stuff on your own I do it's so funny
because I talk a lot about school and
like a lot of teachers and it goes back
to do people see me or don't they when
you have this level of personality when
you do what I do I'm aware that you
could get opposite points of view on
someone on first take and I'm always sad
when people don't realize the the the
main thing I believe in in life is
education the really but how and but how
you receive that correct what I argue is
the packaging and the way we sell
in today's world and definitely the
world I lived in is there's a challenge
to that it doesn't fit the reality of
many human beings and more importantly
there's there's collateral damage to it
because we're teaching people a certain
way and so advertising is
education advertising is commun
absolutely it's communication it's
education it's it's people trying to
conceive and storytelling send a message
entertainment advertising teaching they
all touch in those ways but I love the
way you said it like you know you
believe in education but even in the way
you ask the question being that you're
in the trenches you know the truth you
see every day through the years that
you've been doing this certain kids that
you have complete confidence in your
stomach intuition that they're great
kids and they're going to do great but
this system structured this way doesn't
fit them exactly you see the way human
nature and Instinct Works human nature
and Instinct are are fuel and I
want to hang on to this as long as I
possibly can is curiosity massive
massive you know you watch a kid and
even if that Curiosity ends up you know
right putting the
finger right but that's what happens is
we as a culture will knock that out of
you I know you know this is the way it
is don't even think about this is what
can happen I I saw you on somebody
else's podcast talking about how you
know we're very concerned about what
happened in the past we're very
concerned about how this may turn out
and nobody except you your and your
company and me personally just in my
life you and I do this for my own mental
health live in the now how can we make
now as and I'll use the term profitable
but I that doesn't mean money that
doesn't mean or productive you know just
like how can I Garner happiness how can
I feel like I've achieved something how
can I feel like I've done something
fulfillment and you've always spoken to
that I think that people sometimes
misinterpret this as how can I be
successful and is Success money I don't
think you know that you know listen I
mean I just want to stop this podcast
and go have dinner for nine hours
because this is the only [__] I like
everything yes the answer is yes to what
you just said yes like back to the now
yeah I'm that was in the context of
advertising you can't believe what's
going on in advertising it's so wild
they will hold up a billboard outside or
a literally a newspaper ad or a
television commercial and they will talk
all day about AI is coming and let's do
stuff in the metaverse and yet most of
the Fortune 500 companies in the world
barely think about social media
advertising it's insane to me I well
listen I'm I'm living right now in in
and getting paid and enjoying the fact
and I'm on broadcast television
broadcast television is different is
different than television commerci
commercials every time I talk about
advertising and marketing and
entertainment people like yeah but Gary
people are watching live sports I'm like
watching live sports has no correlation
to where you watching the second
commercial in between a Browns Bears
football game for
Budweiser so to your point but the fact
is I just saw you on CNBC talking about
you know on Black Friday when Amazon is
now the uh the broadcaster of football
on fr the Black Friday game on the Black
Friday game y I would imagine just as a
human being just do it if you see
something right now with a QR code boom
boom boom my my brother did it during
the game the Gillette Razer commercial
came up he everybody now knows how to
use a really or you just represent
Gillette he really did and we and we
really represent Gillette I was going to
get to that point he's like I want to
see how this works and he's it was it's
just insane like literally the
commercial runs he HS the QR code it's
Amazon you know which is the easiest
shopping platform in the world and he's
like this like we were talking about
like this is insane like look where
marketing is now forget about like you
saw a great commercial where's the beef
I saw that commercial in the ' 80s I'm
like Mom I want to go to I want to go to
to Wendy's instead of McDonald's that
was on heard of that's how powerful that
commercial was that doesn't do it
anymore it it does by the way it still
does Mr Beast has something in his video
it still does oh but the speed just the
fact that AJ could buy the yeah that's
it accessibility lack of friction media
you they want I know that Brands will
want something on social media where
they could put a link so it's accessible
right then right there you can buy it in
that moment but not that I'm [__] on
my bosses at social media but I don't
know that the companies are getting the
same value they're not but here's here's
the good your your current bosses like
on network TV the good news is they're
all in the streaming and you know
business right like it's a Evolution
like you know this cuz you're an icon
and and this is fun to give roses as
well you grew up in the in the
entertainment Hollywood ecosystem well
let's get these kids and I mean
everybody who's listening to this a lot
of the biggest platforms came from Radio
to Television right right some of the
most iconic names that you probably as a
kid your grandparents thought were the
biggest stars they started off on radio
right and then the television was
invented right and then they were on
television so when I have now it's
social media that's correct and the
television form is now going to be
streaming and streaming Hulu Amazon
Netflix the way they're going to sell
ads looks more like Instagram and
Facebook than it does look like NBC in
1995 cuz they have all the data and when
you have the data you can make the ads
more targetable I don't want to see ads
that have nothing to do with
me right but what's really tough and
what listen I'm an old guy you're still
a kid compared to me I'm an old guy
these corporations are like the Titanic
you know and they see the iceberg ahead
and they can't steer away from it and I
love that nothing is the same and if you
talk about radio you look at what a hit
was what music sounded like in 1960 even
in 1970 classic rock which I love yeah
that's not that doesn't speak to who is
listening to music right now lead
Zeppelin does not sound like Mumble rap
from the southside of Atlanta and that's
Evolution right and but to your point
you know who else is a big ship going to
an iceberg humans let me
explain the last I love when people are
like oh these corporations they don't
get it they they're slow and I'm like
you were slow 5 years ago I was making
unlimited content saying go to Tik Tok
go to Tik Tok go to Tik Tok but this is
me talking to a friend this is an actual
conversation I'm like you had 500,000
followers on Instagram and that made you
feel good and even though you knew me
and know I've always been right about
this [__] you didn't have the humility
to move mov to Tik Tok and start at zero
because you were just nice and
comfortable here and do you know how
many people listening right now that are
influencers all know exactly what I'm
talking about which is three four years
ago they were like no that's following I
I have 11 million followers on Tik Tok
because of you because I I went there I
saw okay so but the point is but but but
real quick yeah because this is powerful
the fact that you did and the fact that
so many kids that intimately know me and
follow me blindly and fans that I'm
friends with and acquaintances all of
them held on and didn't want to speaks
to curiosity not being a corporation all
those people are one person they should
have been able to move like this Comfort
is not good no [__] right and I love
being uncomfortable me too I love like
even I love thrill rides I love going on
roller coasters not me because I have
some sort of equilibrium thing that's
[__] up and I just throw up on
people I even like getting sick like
don't yeah what are you talking about
aren't you you
don't prove his point than no no I
notice going to be like I like throwing
up no don't no I like getting dizzy what
about dirt what about dirt no that's
different I love dirt that's
uncomfortable well then stay
there disgusting but I love the can I
ask you something how like just now
we're just jamming what about people
like forget about like the joke about
dirt whatever like what about people cuz
one of the things that I'm fascinated by
is my most curious and adap state is
around other people here's the my
problem with people and I agree with you
I love and that's why I love social
media I love listening to people and
learning from people me too as somebody
in a in the business that I'm in and
what I'm known for sometimes when I get
around people they're not they don't
share they want to hear me they want
funny they want me to perform they want
me to so I'm always in a in a very
uncomfortable situation to break that
because as someone who's just now
entering that phase you know I lived a
long life where nobody knew like I was
just a normal guy but now I'm aware of
that and so but because I'm so thirsty
to just chop it up and like do the thing
that I think you like as well I go very
aggressively to break that down as
quickly as possible and make everyone
feel comfortable and change the script
and not me pontificate and fix their
business or their life just like do you
feel like you go on can you go on the
offense to change that script I find I
haven't been able to but I have been
able to that's why I love social media
that's why I'm in the businesses outside
of show business that I'm in you know we
were talking about Proto be the way that
is you know I found that I found a and
and this is some of the other businesses
that I'm in I found them online and I
just slid into a DM and I go how can I
be part of this you can use me for
nothing how entrepreneurial were you as
a kid totally so um I don't have a GED I
don't have uh and I could never fit into
whatever box and maybe because I have a
ADHD and you know I can never sit and
focus and if I'm not interested it's
hard for me to listen I'm dead as well
but I love listening I love entertain me
with information entertain me with a
different way of doing things entertain
me with something that looks and sounds
original entertain me with something
that is nothing I have ever seen or
looked at or heard of before so uh and
and that's that was my thing so I got
thrown out of school which set me into
an incredible depression at 17 all my
other friends were in school and they
have grown and went to college and
become incredibly successful you got
thrown out because you were bad at it or
you did something bad they would say I
did something bad you know I did pranks
they're they uh I I didn't really
understand that I didn't have a TV show
and
I I would do things that have ended up
in as as funny stories and ended up in
movies I I wanted to get out of swimming
I threw a Chu bar in the pool so it
looked like somebody's [__] in the pool
and when the school showed up at the end
of the day to look at the [__] putting
in the pool I dived in and up with it
which you're laughing at now but at 15
years old I was the most disgusting
mature get piece of [__] you could ever
I didn't have a friend in the world so
so um and then I realized I don't come
from a you know I come from a middle
class family who didn't have a lot of
money if I wanted something I had to do
it myself so 12 years old I got myself
three paper roots in in uh in apartment
buildings so I'd have 300 papers you
know and then I went out uh I worked in
a warehouse at a carpet place and then I
saw that they were selling the carpet so
I I made a deal with a a finance company
that if I went door too and sold carpet
and sold it for $15 a month would you
give me the money and then i' go to my
mom's car to deliver the carpet I two
locations I just had a thought because
it just something just clicked me that
I've been a hazy thought how much do you
think there's a direct correlation of
being comfortable on stage and
losing to being able to ring doorbells
and predominantly lose so one of the
reasons I thought public speaking came
natural to me and I only started at
34 and it exploded I was like oh this
makes sense I'm not scared I'm so used
to ringing doorbells and getting nose
this is different this is the same thing
as the crowd not responding to me it's
the same [__] I can get used to this no
you we're using different semantics I am
scared but I like that feeling got it if
put me I am comfortable with discomfort
yeah God I love discomfort discomfort
makes me feel alive yeah me too and the
truth is what I do in my life whether
it's a comedian whether it's a podcaster
whether it's sitting here and talking to
you right now is kind of out of my
comfort zone I'm not comfortable I would
be home it' be much more comfortable to
be sitting at home with my wife and my
kids and watching TV but I love this cuz
I don't know where it's going to go I
don't know what I'm going to get out of
it and by the same token coming from a
middle class Jewish suburb growing up in
an apartment building you know there was
no entrance or even thought of entrance
at the show business to being a comedian
to do what I do to sit here in this
Warehouse that we're sitting in this is
not where I imagine myself being and
when I read into what you did you know
your parents escaped bellarus in 1978
you right so to see them come and start
a new life there's nothing more
uncomfortable to come to a country that
has a totally different language and
culture and everything and I'm sure as a
young pre and pre- internet so like the
speeding up of getting conformed was
impossibly hard and saving up and open a
wine store and then you take that wine
store yes to $60 million a year I think
that's because of the environment the
uncomfortable 100% 100% it's an
entrepreneurial it's a consumer Centric
energy it's why I associate well with
stand up Comics or people in
Entertainment Sports it's Merit based
but you're so do you think that people
that grew up that are comfortable are
kind of at a disadvantage there I do you
do well we need them we need them we and
by the way many of them are able to work
through that just like a lot of us that
didn't have everything as easy have to
work through our stuff but do I think
there is a let me rephrase in the way
that I think you asked the question mhm
do I think it's hard to be hungry when
you've always been fed yes I think
ambition is challenging in that scenario
but some take it the other way I mean
these first of all all these
conversations are incredibly General I
have a friend who I think about every
time I'm thinking about him right now
which is why I'm saying it out loud
every time I talk about it's challenging
if you come from a certain scenario to
be hungry his hunger came from his
awareness that everyone always would
think that he just started on Third and
a half base and so he and so he took
that as motivation and so like every
human's different but I do do I think
environment is a massive impact on a
human being yes I do and so if you grow
up in the east coast in in a certain era
uh in New York City New York tri-state
area you're going to be a certain type
of character versus somebody growing up
in a different environment and I do
think
adversity is the foundation of success I
do believe that but uh you know the Fear
Factor if you're willing
to how I I apologize what do you think
about I agree ABS
Absol no I agree with you but I also
think it could go the other way even I I
believe that I grew up very comfortably
I had a very different lifestyle than
how he grew up um I do also think that
I'm always trying to prove myself and
trying to prove that I'm not necessarily
a neppo baby or get everything because
you give it to me and because I work
hard for the stuff that I that I do and
that I achieve and so I she was a very
successful teacher in the inner city for
10 years I I actually have more empathy
and compassion for her than you because
I think about this every day I so get
you it's why I jumped in I apologize for
interrupting I think your point is so
profound and such an important
conversation and now that we are
starting to have terminology around it
to your point right these are that's
right well now on the podcast but I'm
saying like even when I went into
college I refused to put his name on the
on the applications or like when I went
that's why I
put but like I wanted to know that I was
getting in on my own Merit on my own
hard work it's the number one thing I I
couldn't understand that more the the
the empathy and compassion I have for
children who because remember how you
and I got the luck of the draw of
certain DNA skill sets right let just
play it out and it's very common for our
children to potentially get that as well
the difference is to your point I think
it's harder I actually believe this I
think that it is harder emotionally if
you are someone who's wired a certain
way to have your circumstance with a dad
like that then the reverse absolutely
yeah because you can never win no and
and they go through a hard time you know
my son who is you know this is going to
sound like NE but he's the producer of
this podcast he's only the producer of
this this podcast because he has a huge
um
face I see it I'm seeing it it's a good
face son yeah I see him looking right at
him big face okay got good face but he
is I'm not equally proud of all my
children but I about 20 years ago yep I
called him he's in his mid-30s now I
called him at home at 2:00 in the
afternoon and I woke him up and I said
what the [__] are you doing what the
[__] are you doing he's sleeping dad
right yeah he was sleeping yeah and I
said you you got to get you got to get a
job a parent you got to get a job you
got he goes I I work I go what do you
mean you work he goes I was up all night
working I go what were you doing he goes
well we were downtown dropping balloons
off the buildings and I go I don't
understand that that's a job and this is
before I knew what YouTube was love and
what happened was he started when
YouTube started Y and when youed to and
then he realized well I don't need to be
on camera I'm noticing that all these
influencers need uh need
content so what I'm going to do I'm
creative I'm going to sell them I'm
going to do content for everybody else
and shareing their a every so he has a
ton of things I remember I don't know if
you remember the mouth guard challenge
he created that that's awesome you know
and then sold it and licensed it and
made a ton of money doing that he did a
lot of things that you see influencers
doing my son has a hand in and he's
behind the scenes and everything but
that was incredibly
entrepreneurial makes sense and
everything that she has done and her
sister has done I don't know what I
instilled except for the fact that I
instilled that
success success is for me is not money
it's not notoriety it's not likes it's
the ability to get up each and every day
and kind of be excited about what you're
going to do there is no confusion to me
of what you connected with when you
started seeing what I was saying I could
not agree with another voice that went
oh my God this kid this is what I've
been SC you're much more eloquent you
sell it a lot better than I've ever sold
it because I just and and that's why I
think that everybody and maybe I
probably have a little bit of a
different audience than you you got to
follow Gary V not to become wealthy not
to become successful to figure out how
to live your life can I jump in right
now you just something just happened
that I'm like obsessed with not to be
wealthy check fully agree not to be
success
that one is probably going to be my next
50 years if we can somehow and you said
it if we can somehow redefine success in
popular culture we will change this
[__] world well what right because
right like you said I know you agree
with me and I think words matter back to
eloquence and like semantics if we can
redefine success to waking up and being
calm do you know how many people wake up
happy joyful calm like like man if I
could just eliminate the anxiety of the
world around dumb [__] the [__] that
people are anxious about but not only
anxious about unhappy about you know
when when in in traditional radio which
barely exists anymore yes the term we're
we're doing it right now it's just
called it's new yeah hump day yes you
know that term of Wednesday is Wednesday
which is halfway through the [__] you
don't want to do you get to the just so
you don't have to do the [__] you one of
my one of my most successful posts in
the history of my 15-year content career
was if you live for the weekends your
[__] is broken right and I know this
because school was a disaster for me and
when I tell you Friday was do you know I
should have been a weatherman Howe when
I tell you that when there was a
potential snow day I turned into
literally a scientist I would I knew
everything I mean I the Doppler radar
was the most I probably had a poster of
the Doppler radar in my high school like
I disliked school so much that I would
live for Friday at 3 p.m. lived for it
lived for it and that was fine and I
understood that and then somewhere in my
30s when this all started happening I
was like wait a minute because then I
went into my happy Zone a grownup and
lived I was like wait a minute this is
how most people live their life this is
not sustainable I knew I was getting out
at some point this is what people were
doing for 50 years and that got me
passionate and that's why I talk about
what I talk about but is it isn't it is
it a problem with people and individuals
or our society and businesses and
culture and the way that corporations
and work maybe the older generation look
at the way you're supposed to number one
your point is amazing and I know where
you're going and I'm a buyer yeah I'm
just obsessed with human
accountability it's so hard though for
the younger generation go in there I
want to everything is hard yeah it's
supposed to be life is like I no I love
what this is a very interesting topic
because I I'm a buyer I look I love
America I'm a I'm an entrepreneur I love
capitalism but when things go too far
it's not good like to your point popular
culture of what's good and what's
successful like I'm I'm like such a
buyer of like what do we put out in
culture right but I also think it goes
both ways let me explain so where you're
going I'm such a buyer of if it's
pounded in our face constantly this is
what success looks like it's hard on the
flip side we do things like give eighth
place trophies to kids now cuz we we
think that's the right thing to do like
we're always as a society going to get
into places where we go too far left too
far right which is why the first part
matters which is if you don't have the
capacity to be humanly um accountable to
you here's a good example back to
fatherhood and kids your your parents
told you things the world told you
things there are things that you decided
to do differently
right the end so just because the
world's telling you a [__] Gucci belt
is the right thing well I'm telling you
it's not so who you going to listen to
this person or that person there is
always a counter voice and a lot of
counter voices there's unlimited people
that tell you money's
horrible and and corporations are
horrible to me this but this is an
important point I I think this is very
big because I don't think the there's
right I think there's right for you and
the more that we give the power away and
blame parents corporations social media
this that and the other thing the
further we're getting away from the
truth which is we're capable I believe
in humans you just you just hit it
though that's my problem my problem is
you have to know that you are
responsible listen as somebody who's
really deep into mental health yes um
you are responsible for your own
well-being you really are nobody else is
you're responsible for your own
happiness if somebody else is making you
unhappy that's just how you are reacting
that person you can't change that person
you can only change how you react to
that person and all the divisiveness
that we have in our world now
politically socially is because people
go we hate them you know what they're
doing this is why I can't afford this is
why I'm not up there this is why I'm not
happy and that doesn't take away
systematic truths like well when you go
off the gold standard when there's a
bigger separation of wealth like I'm not
an absolutist I'm very purple when it
comes to a lot of these conversations I
don't find myself very red or blue no
either do I but and so to your point I
believe in everything you said comma
there's also other macro circumstances
right like there's a million things that
go on in life here's my thing though the
second you decide that you can't it's
over and one thing I know for sure is
the world is how you see it if you
decide there's [__] and it sucks and
it's the worst you can find it all day
long
and if you decide it is good and
opportunistic and good you can
absolutely find it all day long and so
the question becomes do you have the
capacity to adjust if it isn't going
well well in in in very understandable
black and white terms there are people
that make more money in a market
correction you know when it crashes than
they do when it's booming so you found a
way to have the negative work for you
and yeah or or the things I stay up at
night and think about which is when I
think about somebody in my life who
makes $67,000 a year and genuinely
enjoys every day and wakes up Monday
through Sunday thrilled and has the
things that make them feel fulfilled
their family a job that they like that's
only 9 to5 cuz that's why they're making
67,000 but that gives them unlimited
capacity to be part of the bowling team
and go to everything that their kids do
and it allows them to work on their
music at night and they are thrilled and
the and the way more people I know that
make millions of dollars a year that are
in dark ass places I can go in my phone
right now now from A to Z and rattle off
off the Record to you one by one
hundreds of people I actively know right
now that are not in good places who make
unlimited money well I'll tell you I've
had a lot of struggles mentally and just
maintaining happiness and I'm I do well
and have done well but I I you know and
my issues are uh biological sometimes
that's right that's a circumstance that
is a circumstance and it's a real one
for people but I've fig figured out how
to uh well this is why this is why you
have so much conviction for this
subject you have so much conviction for
this subject and so you've found your
way to work through it and so you you
are deeply passionate that you know
there's other people on the other side
of this listening and they don't think
they have a capacity and they do we all
do I brother I believe why do you think
I'm so [__] happy every day I believe
I believe you a happy guy yes I'm an
extremely happy guy do you work hard
hard to be happy something you
constantly work at no no I don't or I do
constantly let's talk it through my
natural reaction to you is
no I don't know what part of me let's
talk about let's break it down because I
think you'll find this interesting my my
mom lost her mom at five my dad lost his
dad at 15 I can tell you the majority of
my childhood I thought about my parents
dying it was a constant flow so I
constantly worked in my head as a 7 9 11
13y old child hey I woke up hey this is
another day that they're here this is
good this is a good day so I naturally
say to you no I don't have to work at it
because I'm at a 48-year Old State and I
forget and I'm trying to tap in harder
to like talk this through with you
mentally I always am talking to myself
about perspective that's half yes I
think about things I'll tell this is
like real life to me I know it's a
little weird or not talked about as much
but I'll sit here I'll do this podcast
this is so lovely what we're doing now
I'm enjoying this and I'll then like
literally take the feelings I have right
right now which is a lot of joy and
energy and like as we transition and
walk out and talk with team photos talk
a little bit talk about this startup
like as we do that a part of my brain
will be like hey this will really happen
hey G do you know since you've been here
with them like a lot of people passed
away in a bad car accident yeah how I
told you it's a little weird so much
have full anymore no no it's actually I
would almost call it extreme
gratitude it's this constant flow in my
head of like just deep Gra itude and
it's a constant conversation and so it's
funny I acted very fast and say to you
no but boy I'm not sure how many people
on earth walk around and are constantly
talking themselves about perspective and
keeping [__] simple and like just be
grateful for what's going and yes this
is challenging this is hard in personal
life this is hard at work but like [__]
as long as these 17 10 nine people that
are closest to me are healthy then like
today's a great [__] day and that
helps me a lot so so maybe I am working
at it so and it's a constant there's
nobody that's just happy happiness
doesn't happen contentment doesn't
happen relationships don't just happen
well that one's for sure it's a it's a
because the first one's one-on-one
basketball it's you with you right you
start bringing another variable in
that's a whole another world and not to
be negative but you know the longer you
live I'm an old guy the longer you live
how old are you you said it 14 times in
this [__] show already I know I just
had a birthday yesterday uh did you yeah
68 it's great I just turned 48 so I got
20 years on you I was an adult I was
almost a drinking age when you were born
no you were actually it used to be 18
your ER I'm not in Canada got it it was
18 it was 18 19 now yeah then my parents
lied to me yeah I think just you're so
old you forgot yeah that's the
first no but but what I'm saying Howe
how about this though actually let's
talk about I love that let's talk about
this something little back to more
sunshine how about the fact could you
have ever imagined at 20 years old that
68-year-old you would be this hungry
this alive this many more plans of the
future I know tell these kids out here
they're [__] 27 years old and they
think their life's over here's what I
say here's what I say this is my
philosophy My Philosophy is yes it's
just yes never say no no is n o no o are
the first two letters of the word
nothing nothing comes from no if you say
yes even if it's a horrible experience
you learn something and by the and and
everything good that has happened in my
life everything different has come out
of yes I was an entrepreneur why you
laughing I feel like you guys should go
on tour together for motivational
speaking I don't only no no first of all
that's probably right but you have to
come with us really yeah she's got two
kids at
home she doesn't follow my philosophy
but here's here here's the thing you
know I was can I can I interrupt yeah
let's talk about this moment we just had
uhhuh how much do you think of what me
and Dad are talking about right now is
delusional real talk no I don't think
any of it well I've heard it my whole
life but to me it's second naturee like
I hear this all the time so I don't
think it's delusional keep breaking it
down for me so you've heard it all your
life you obviously now like from from
the beginning to where we are now she
doesn't practice it yes I do yes I
do is
well maybe is yeah maybe is but by the
way honestly what I'm trying to do right
now is like I'm obsessed with value I'm
thinking right now also like people are
listening to this right and like what
can we bark up what tree can the three
of us bark up right now that might
unlock a sentence that genely positively
impacts someone and what I'm sensing and
it's why I love it because I I actually
find it very valuable the energy that's
in this room right now what part of it
is Ish is is it the part that you asked
me earlier of like does it come natural
to you do you like default into you are
both it's very foreign to me because I
am a very anxious person and have social
anxiety and most of my thoughts have to
do with how people view me Bingo yeah so
I I am fearful and I say no often
because I'm always fearful of how others
are going to perceive me first of all I
love you with all my [__] heart I'm
being dead [__] serious with you the
thing that just happened in the last
minute is what I spend every waking hour
on
if we can somehow as a society double
click into that because I believe
everything that is a struggle is based
on that I mean take it to the [__]
Moon you want to bring up any issue I
will tell you right now that is
something I'm spending ungodly amounts
of time on which is God that's hard I'm
so I so get it like the thought of that
is such a challenge and people live
their entire lives based on it live
that's that's our culture why do you get
up why do you comb your hair before you
answer the
door you know why why do you even put
your fingers through your hair because
when you answer the why do you put your
fingers through your hair because it's
in the other room there where it's
cooler yes but here's but but what I was
what I was about to say like even for oh
go ahead yeah I'm just I'm I'm really
feeling it cuz I think it's going cuz I
think what I think what no it's funny
I'd rather hear her than us cuz I cuz I
actually think she's tapping in I think
Jack Jack Jack I think you're tapping
into the biggest conversation in our
society because for
me I think it I'm going to throw a weird
one at you I think it's because most
people lack empathy let me explain if if
you worry about somebody's judgment
which makes sense everyone has a version
of that we all
do when someone doesn't reciprocate
nicely to your outfit to the words you
said to whatever it is to whatever the
way you live your life something in my
brain and it took me a long time to
realize this is what I was doing cuz all
this stuff gets got me there
I feel bad if someone's mean to me for
them right and I haven't gotten there
yet and I've gone through years of
therapy talking about it my social
anxiety and stuff and I haven't figured
it out yet I haven't tapped into how
about the empathy
part what do you mean I have empathy
when so when you don't feel bad for them
when they don't react well to you no I
me feel that no [__] this is I'm going
back to it
empathy let's take let's break this down
someone wants to hurt
you that can only mean they're
hurt can it it does it yeah it's
completely foreign to someone to hurt
someone for no damn reason when they're
in a good place it's completely foreign
so uh can I argue with you for a second
it's the only reason we're here okay to
argue I said on and argue with me I
thought we were going to have some lunch
or something together no but here's the
thing as somebody and you must feel this
more as somebody who is a public figure
and and like I am I'm fascinated by the
fact that somebody feels that they have
the cart blanch to say things to you and
me they
do they no they don't of course they do
so when I first shaved my head I
remember I see somebody in an elevator
and they go oh you shaved your head you
had such beautiful curly hair you look
so much better with hair who says that
to somebody somebody who's deeply
subconscious not in a great place you
really think so I really do I believe
without even realizing it something's
going in a way where they're in a need
for Raz they're in resentment there
there there's I yes I believe it
actually it might be the only thing I
believe in I'm serious that's how much I
believe in it I believe that they not
always consciously but subconsciously
decided in their moment with you to
decide to do something that would
actually Raz you or hurt you because
they are not in a good place I really
believe that that would never in a
million years happen to me to do to
somebody else well me too I am so
concerned about I don't want to hurt
your feelings I that's called that's
called empathy no we that's a big and it
and it comes in two ways Jack's
absolutely right I don't think Jackie
would do that either never I'm always
concerned about whether or not I hurt
someone's feelings that's part of my
anxiety too but number two is the big
one the empathy the second tier of the
empathy in this conversation is
understanding when someone's doing
something wrong
it's about them not you it's attachment
from you it's it's that's so powerful to
me the truth is it doesn't really matter
what somebody thinks of you it's not
changing your life what they think of
but that's that's easy to say but when
it your chemicals feel it it's
impossible I I'll you you'll find this
is very weird I'm sorry Jackie I'm going
to give you the example but this is why
I can attach with it I I apologize so
intervention no honestly
with my child I was having trouble with
my child showed up and just made her a
better person first of all I like her
quite a bit no I really I really feel
for this you're this is I now you're I'm
going to completely lose you I feel like
maybe something Good's happening here
and I'm about to lose everyone including
the audience let me explain why I
understand this okay I understand this
because I'm a New York Jets
fan I'm telling you please stick my
husand told me to bring this up to you
by the way he a Jet fan okay first of
all I knew I liked you what's his what's
his name Alex Alex cuz I [__] really
like you can't wait to have I'm being
serious there's one place in my life
where you can't have
success where where I really have Envy
where I really have Envy where I really
have negative feelings that I can't
control where I don't feel great and
it's watching Jet games I'm being
serious I have tremendous issues with
like Patriot fans I'm I'm jealous I'm
like you and and and I see it manifest
in my behavior and and and it's just
really and I and I attack and I Raz and
I do things and um and I don't feel good
about like it's very easy for me to tap
into the way people think about politics
and the way people think about other
things in the world based on that and
it's because I'm not in a good
place cuz I and here's the big one and
you're going to love this back to
accountability it's also cuz I'm not in
control got it all my feelings are
wrapped up in what they're doing and I
can't do anything about it so when you
think your parents did everything and
you can't do anything about it and you
spend your entire life blaming your
parents you're dead like people don't
get it they don't they don't you are
actually fully in control you you don't
uh ready we have an election year coming
up you don't like who wins move to
Sweden you
can you don't like it it's so bad this
is the worst move or how does it really
affect your personal life this is where
people got into in the 70s and 80s after
a lot of social discontent in the 60s
they're going to go through it again
you're going to start realizing like
crying about it 24/7 surely doesn't
accomplish anything right and so just
it's a game of understanding people and
I think or understanding yourself well
sure and so like look insecurity is a
natural human trait but how does having
empathy for that other person that's
putting you down how does that help you
it first of all it changes the framework
of the whole isn't it better to not care
not care is not possible when you're
insecure you're insecure because you
care about what everybody thinks you by
Nature are that so it's not going to do
you any good me and you saying Jackie
don't care she's like okay [__] faces
cool for you but like it's just not how
my chemicals work that'd be like telling
you and I stop doing
[__] like it's just not wired that way
what it does is it adds a layer of
perspective that can be worth thinking
about which is which is all of a sudden
Jackie like something happens and
somebody says something it would be a
normal thing that she would normally get
upset about judging the way she parents
or something about Alex or or real about
you like real [__] I'm not talking funny
real quick Howe and all of a sudden
instead of being like going into her
feelings she's created a pattern of like
man Susan the neighbor must be going
through some tough [__] cuz there was
really no reason for her to say
that and so it takes her energy to a
different
place it's interesting because I've
never had I always have him or my
husband's like why does it matter don't
listen to it doesn't compute in my head
that's right jack I fully disagree with
them it won't work for you what will
work for you is the teacher that said
that or or your dad saying this or me
saying that why did we say
that as if you why did you yell at me
the other
day you must be in a really bad
place by the way I it's fixed now yeah
is it I know sorry about leaving you at
the circus oh thank you you left her at
the circus yes by accident I this is
where a lot of my issues have came from
well good
news that sucks comma comma always think
of the positive your your parent left
you at the circus yep but there's a
positive of course there's a positive
which is I don't know it yet you go that
you get to make fun of him on a podcast
about it oh there we go you're [__]
parent Dad no but Jack listen you you
and Jack you know what happens to you
know what happens to everybody what what
happens is one day your kids are going
to tell you everything that you sucked
at uhhuh and I hear it all the time
that's right you're old enough to tell
her 9-year-old tells me all the oh wait
till that 9-year-old's 23 so you feel
bad for her because she's doing that no
no no no I feel bad for me I'm telling
you nine and 23 are two different games
well I was really I was horrible when
did your parents support you fully even
in your everything as a student
yes my mom a couple things first of all
my dad had no clue what was going on he
worked every minute of my life right
literally didn't meet the guy until I
was 14 okay but even though we slept
under the same roof every night I get it
and I admire that okay there's you know
of course I would have loved for him to
like when my brother was 11 years
younger and he went to his basketball
game I'm like I wish you went to one of
my baseball of course what kid doesn't
right but back to thinking about
them you know man this man came from
another country at 22 we lived in like
when you start deploying empathy for
them when you make when you make nothing
about
you when you make nothing about you [__]
gets real interesting real fast you seem
to have a lot of answers but you seem to
be I one of my biggest um tools yes for
um just being able to survive is is uh I
I kind of distract myself by being busy
do you ever turn off and and uh
constantly really and are you good with
yourself yeah I like I equally like
being lonely like by myself as I do
being with everyone look I'm my let me
let me go a different direction where I
think you're going let me talk to you
about my cryp Tonite the things that
were tough for me Gary ve on a podcast
cander
King cander King Gary vaynerchuk the
real human being if I care about you at
all Dustin Tyler people that worked for
me couldn't deliver it if it was bad
news hated the
conflict did not want to tell people
always thought I could figure out a
different way to get you a company like
that when you're so uncomfortably
talented you can disguise it but when I
had to look at myself in my early 40s
called six seven years ago and was like
wait a minute if I'm such a great guy
and I'm and I don't care about the if
I'm all what I want to be why are there
people that have worked for me that
don't feel great about me you got to be
accountable right and what I realized
was when I really sat down and had that
chapter with myself it's because they
were surprised when I fired
them cuz I wasn't able to give them
cander along the way Howie have a great
weekend you're working for three years
everything's literally we've never had
one conversation of anything going wrong
Friday you and I walking in the D
Warehouse Howe have the best [__]
weekend bro [__] have the best
weekend d d d Monday you come in Howe
can you see me for a few minutes Howe
listen we're going to have to let you go
the [__] are you talking about Gary like
bro and then in my brain I'm like how
you've sucked for 2 and 1/2 years
everyone knows it like why are you make
like and I would put it on them I wasn't
accountable that I didn't have the gear
in me to tell them the things that
weren't wrong my capacity was very high
cuz I didn't value the money enough I
like to be a coach and a guidance coun I
want to build them up I I knew in those
three years I'd figure out a different
way to get them eventually to your point
how do you run a company like that
eventually there's a Tipping Point but
instead of being
accountable that it was on me for for
not doing the things ahead of time to
not surprise them I would blame them of
like being like delusional you changed
that trust me I would not be talking
about it out loud if I haven't changed
it so there that and that's really
difficult for you very difficult and
it's it's back to work the reason I
believe like health and wellness I was
38 years old I didn't have a muscle in
my body and I ate nothing good and I
just one day at 38 and a half said when
I get to be 40 when on my 40th birthday
I'm going to start taking care of myself
not right in that moment you were wait 2
years to do it when you don't do
something for 38 years it's hard to
think about doing it but by the time I
easy to think about doing it it's hard
to do I always call it where there's
smoke there's fire most of the best
things that have ever happened to me
have sat in my head for a year so you're
giving yourself realistic expectations
as opposed to just saying I'm starting
right this moment knowing that you
probably well what happened in this one
was by the you'll love this I was in
Houston I was on a plane head on the
window I was like [__] like just like I
love life and like I need to live longer
like like I can't be out here telling
people good things to think about and
not trying to make myself better this
health thing is not good like not that
by the way there was nothing wrong it
was nothing like I got a bad doctor
report I was just being self-aware and
accountable I was like I don't do
anything right this is probably going to
run out at some time I don't go to the
gym and I don't eat well and so here's
the cool part Jack I that I go okay I'm
my 40th like I literally I'm like trying
to I'm my 40th birthday somewhere
between Houston and New York somewhere
over like Tennessee or something I'm
like why wait the four I'm going to do
39 6 months 39 by the time I landed I
called a former trainer that I like
backed out on like 31 out of 35 sessions
and said I need help and I figured out
something my greatest place is when I'm
a leader I feel very accountable to them
and so once I figured out if I hire a
full-time trainer who's really with me
and travels with me I'm not going to
want to let him or her down it was him
him down and that worked for me and it
shifted and because that came so hard
for me
still to this day I've been working out
and eating much better for 10 years
every day I wake up I don't want to do
it every day but because I worked
through it I believe in what I said to
you now that if just for some way you
tweak it and you decide every time
someone shits on you that you feel bad
for them and hope they're better versus
focusing on what you're feeling about
their judgment I don't know if that's
going to work for you or not I don't I'm
hoping it h it helps one or two people
that are listening cuz it's a real
perspective shift and I've watched it in
my face change people's lives oh listen
you're speaking you're preaching to the
the you know what in these comments now
all the shitty comments I'm going to get
which might be a few I'm going to
respond and say I feel bad for you hey
Jack hey Jack I feel bad for you hey
Jack yeah do you know that as I built my
career I basically Built My Career on
Twitter from 2007 to 11 what are you
what is your career what what I'm an
entrepreneur an entrepreneur I'm an
operator I I run a 20 a 2100 person
advertising agency which is I'm the
day-to-day CEO I run V friends which is
my poke I love this Bobby like I always
want when I saw you do this years ago
this like 20 years now right yeah 91
more than 20 30 yeah good he did the
math I used to grow up on yeah like when
that like I've been watching animation
like Bobby like I've been watching this
I heard you you signed a deal right to
do a show I I created this Pokemon meets
Sesame Street brand called V friends yes
I operate that every day like on the
drive in between these podcasts I'm on
business meetings like I'm a pure bread
entrepreneur but the but the new version
of everyone has the capacity to have a
platform to communicate who's producing
it what's that your Show Oh you mean uh
so I am so Eric wattenberg used to be at
CA we started a production company
called Vayner wat and so we're we're
making it but I think everybody now has
the capacity to have a platform whether
they're famous to 15 people or to 5,000
or to 50 million like the things are
changing in society but I like when I
can see that people are trying to both
do something for themselves but do
something for others in their platform
and that's cool do you feel more
pressure now because you do have such a
big audience that listens to you and
values your opinion that when you say
something they take it to heart and they
listen they like they will do it whether
it's business I don't I don't feel it as
pressure but I do feel it as responsib I
do I am thoughtful about it in a way
that I used to not be now the good news
is I've always known I've had good
intent it's not like it's been it's
light for me cuz I know like I always
tell my team I'm like intent is how we
judge our team cuz business is always a
gamble like it life is a gamble yeah
some people have less to gamble on and
they and they listen to well the good
news is I'm never saying like go do this
I'm saying like here are some things out
there be self like my it's easy for me
because I'm not looking for absolutes
I'm not like you need to buy real estate
in Texas right I'm saying things like
are you self-aware do you know what you
like are you reverse engineering
strengths and interests
here are some macro Trends there's
things going on on Tik Tok I'll give one
right now Tik Tok live is a
beast how is a beast Howie right now if
you went on Tik Tok live for three hours
a day yeah you would be flabbergasted
what you should do the you should do
that ooh like you know the girls that do
like every time they get a gift they do
like a
different are you saying you want him to
do an only fans or like yeah I wasn't
sure wasn't sure yeah that's not only
yeah no I get it I know the digital
gifts know what she's listen but what
are you saying I'm just saying this for
the whole audience of entrepreneurs and
you included Tik Tok so the way I see
the world is there are moments in time
where attention on a platform is
misunderstood or underestimated okay
1980s HBO standup special yeah TRL on
MTV in the 90s right um what I do for a
living 5 years ago Tik Tok or email
marketing in 1997 how I built my Daddy's
Liquor Store okay so I'm always watching
for underpriced distribution in media
Landscapes right the current one as we
sit here this second is Tik Tok live for
three because I'll go on Tik Tok live a
lot but I I you know I'll spend a half
hour the longer the better because the
way that algo is working and the way I'm
seeing it from my perch is Tik Tok is
really testing their live product and
they're helping more exposure for the
people that are committing more to the
platform so the longer you're on it
you're growing unlike a platform like
Instagram live where you go on and you
can see the audience dip right because
all they're doing is informing your
entire audience and then everyone comes
and then a percentage goes away what Tik
tok's doing is you go live and it's
showing up in the algorithms and people
are discovering
you wow can I go Tik Tok live now no
let's not let's not why because you
always do this I don't want to do it
right now like you got to go yep you
have to go yep now is okay so Tik Tok
live is thing no but I'll wrap it up
because I want to I want to show you
something we'll wrap it up I I could
talk to you for days and days and days I
love you I you're man I wish I wish I
I'm sorry to interrupt and I'm sure by
the way that's something that I got to
work on too I get too excited but you
can't imagine how that makes me feel you
are a [__] Legend well so are you
yeah but like you're 68 so you've been
doing it longer and it just I didn't
become a legend and I'm just a legend
just because I'm old now but you are no
but what's interesting is you're my
favorite kind of Legend but here's the
thing I do what I do without knowing or
have been able to articulate what I do
you articulate I go listen to this kid I
was watching you and I go and I've
showed you his stuff I go this is what I
keep telling you look at this but but
but what's cool about this is what I
mean is that all of us me you jack
Dustin Tyler the crew we always have
tweaks right I loved what you said about
you know Alex and your dad like saying
who cares who cares car M we may be
saying the same thing but it's these
this is the point it's slight tweaks and
perspectives that can actually unlock
because I don't think telling someone
who does care about it don't care that
just doesn't work what I think is go to
a deeper truth which
is man could you actually imagine living
like no no [__] for the three of us
could you imagine living a life where
you spend most of your time trying to
hurt other people's
feelings cuz that's what a lot of people
do I don't know that aware of it they're
not they think they think they're
keeping it real so when I say subscribe
and comment I mean do it in a positive
way too good you anything you want uh
them to go to Chuck-E-Cheese
chuckecheese is nice uh I want them to
go to within themselves and like finally
realize like why not let this be the
podcast that unlocked a finally a
different conversation with yourself and
you can realize you can get out of the
shitty marriage you can lose weight you
can quit a job you can start the thing
like [__] you're going to be dead
forever and you know like device is quit
the job Leave Your Wife And so there's
going to be a lot of people that are
unemployed but like or or before you get
to that extreme how about having
something I struggle with how about
having a canderous conversation with
your boss and tell them what you're
struggling with respectfully how about
talking to your spouse about the things
that you're struggling with look this is
me talking about [__] I'm giving my self
advice cander to the people around me is
the core thing I need to work on but the
one thing I don't have to work on is
fear and I think the world runs on fear
and you need to figure out why you're
scared who judgment do you know how many
people don't do things because they're
worried about what their mom's going to
think everyone everyone you got it my
man and by the way that doesn't mean who
gives a [__] about your mom or [__] your
mom that doesn't mean that it means be
empathetic to why she thinks what she
thinks but you have to live your life
because you're going to resent everyone
if you don't except don't [__] your mom
no definitely don't do that was more
[__] comma
mom got you didn't see Thea yeah I got
it I didn't see it you're the best I
love you brother thank you for having me
on thank you Jackie thank you thank you
thank you
[Music]
Gary